I thought the prior conversation that  Joe had on the the prospects of a  recession at about 50 50. that seems  right to me so we don't want to get  caught out New Jersey's been caught out  before uh and we are determined not to  get caught out again our job is to make  sure we deliver affordability that we've  got enough in the bank for a rainy day  and that we outperform other like States  and those are our obsessions right now  Murphy thinks there's a 50 50 chance of  recession that's the bad news the worst  news is that there's actually a 100  chance of recession because we have  officially been in a recession since  July 28th because a recession is defined  as two consecutive quarters of negative  GDP growth and we're there and we've  been there for a while